[Music]
my name is Sasha angular's I'm the
president of the union of French Jewish
students and one of its main goals is to
fight against racism and anti-semitism
the attacks are becoming more and more
violent and the way people are getting
used to you can see semitism and
considering that anti-semitism has to be
lived to East and is not something that
you can fight against the violence of
the threat has been obviously noted in
the killings that happened three years
ago in Toulouse where children are shot
in a school two months ago the attacks
in the Jewish Museum a person was
perpetrated by a French dinner and the
particularity of these past weeks is
that we have witnessed attacks of large
groups of people heading at synagogues
heading at Jewish quarters trying to
harm Jews and in the past we had more
observed individual attacks and now we
are seeing phenomenal attacks by large
groups of people obviously there are
economic reasons but you can't just boil
it down to social and economic reasons
it's not only because of the crisis
because people are searching for the
far-right because they don't accept it
immigration now they want to blame
immigrants on the programs that are
happening and it's something that can be
seen all over Europe never been so
strong in front
they don't really accept this ad that
the attacks when the Jews only would
only be committed by research category
of procreation because we have seen that
conservatism comes from all sorts of
backgrounds I mean you don't know
whether recent attacks and they were
carried out by people who are
participating to Palestinian
pro-palestinian protests and there is to
a certain extent and identification
between certain ranges of Muslims and
Palestinians but it's only a limited
identification and you have a lot of
people who take part of these protests
who are not Muslims but you still
believe that Jews are all Rainey's or
all Israelis and that they need to be
attacked they not see what's happening
in France are the war between religion
or the war between communities I think
it's a wider program and the fact that
the National Front is arrived first in
the election is an indicator that there
is climates and friends where people are
trying to blame others for what's
happening rather than trying to be in
favor of solution that would include
everyone's participation so they are
person for negative project rather than
a presence in violence
[Music]